sto is an open platform to connect  manage and secure micro services let's  see what it takes to install and run a  steel on google kubernetes engine or gke  first create a kubernetes cluster on gke  with g-cloud container clusters create  command make sure your classes that is  using to parent is 1.9 or nearer and  grant admin permissions to the current  g-cloud user now download the latest is  tier version  and add east your CTL command-line tool  to your path now we are ready to install  East EOS core components we will install  the optional earth components  this creates SEO system namespace and  deploys the four primary control plane  components pilot mixer ingress a  certificate authority let's quickly  verify the installation and that's it  that's all it takes to install is D on  GK